[Musique]
je vous apprendrez rien en vous disant
que la biodiversité va mal sur la
planète
un million d'espèces animales et
végétales sont menacées d'extinction la
forêt amazonienne qui ratisse il y a des
drapeaux rouges qui sont levés partout
nos écosystèmes sont dégradés à hauteur
de 70% d'échelle du globe et bien qu'on
ne veut pas l'entendre l'être humain en
évidemment responsable et pensez pas que
c'est différent chez nous le caribou est
loin d'être le seul sur la liste des
espèces menacées au Canada une espèce
sauvage sur cinq est menacée on laisse
quoi comme type de planète aux
prochaines génération
en décembre dernier à Montréal pendant
la COP15 190 pays ont signé une marche à
suivre pour freiner l'effondrement du
vivant
le monde la finance a été présenté par
plusieurs comme un levier essentiel pour
restaurer la planète les investisseurs
doivent être les alliés de la nature non
des ennemis on a profité de la
conférence pour poser une question bien
simple si on dit que l'argent mène le
monde doit-on donner une valeur à la
nature pour la sauver
s'il y a une notion qu'on a perdu de vue
c'est notre dépendance à la nature
pensons-y un peu à une échelle plus
individuelle
la nourriture qu'on mange à pousser dans
la richesse du sol
notre maison est construite en deux par
quatre des pinèdes
on s'habille de coton
on se chauffe au bois
ou à l'hydroélectricité
pour voiture carbure au pétrole et
maintenant ou
ces services qui nous sont rendus par la
nature s'appellent des services
écosystémiques si on parle d'argent plus
de la moitié du PIB mondial dépend de la
nature
quand la biodiversité va mal c'est la
capacité de la nature à maintenir ses
services qui est en danger et aussi de
l'économie qui est à risque
on s'en va à la COP15 qui est la
conférence internationale sur les
questions biodiversité merci
c'est impressionnant pareil il y a plus
de policiers en ville que le marché
comment va la biodiversité dans la
province on s'en va poser la question à
Alain Webster un spécialiste de la
question qui vient tout juste de
remettre un rapport sur la biodiversité
au Québec votre rapport dit très
clairement il faut revoir notre rapport
à la nature ça veut dire quoi
essentiellement on a pris cette relation
avec l'environnement souvent comme étant
une capacité de générer des ressources
naturelles qu'on pouvait exploiter
attention parce que c'est plus compliqué
qu'on pensait
ces écosystèmes doivent être
fonctionnels pour permettre d'obtenir un
ensemble de services écosystémiques mais
quand cet environnement se dégrade à
long terme de façon significative
l'environnement père mais surtout nous
perdons on va juste arrêter ça parce que
Étienne je voudrais pas que le T-Rex
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'un des objectifs les plus connus de la
COP15 c'est celui de protéger 30%
30% 30% du territoire et des Océans ici
20 30
la science estime que de protéger des
écosystèmes permet de maintenir les
services qu'il nous rendent mais aussi
de donner à la nature assez de
résilience pour faire face aux
conséquences des changements climatiques
actuellement ce sont les gouvernements
qui conservent la majorité des
territoires protégés mais à la COP15 des
acteurs du monde financier sont venus
dire qu'ils pouvaient faire leur part
c'est le cas de fonds de placement mis
en place par la CSN
à travers l'une de ces filiales le fond
vient de se lancer dans un projet qui
génère des profits en conservant des
milieux naturels
on s'en va en parler avec la PDG
Geneviève Morin
est-ce que vous sentez madame Morin un
vent de changement en ce qu'après à
l'implication de la finance lorsqu'on
parle des questions de biodiversité
j'avais les gens de la finance c'est du
monde normal c'est des gens aussi il y a
des jeunes qui rentrent dans les milieux
financiers il y a un intérêt qui se
développe de plus en plus pour dire il
faudrait qu'on puisse comme financer
faire tout ce qu'on peut le rythme
auquel les choses vont la quantité de
consommation qui se passe en ce moment
c'est pas un rythme qui est sous table
on utilise une un point 6 planètes par
année mais on a juste une il faut
l'utiliser comme il faut donc cette
réflexion là elle est démarrée
fond d'action investie dans la
protection et la grandement de la
whippbbury Mountain trésor ou Vermont
une réserve naturelle privée comment
faire de l'argent avec ça par
l'entremises des crédits carbone
prenons une minute pour comprendre le
fonctionnement du marché du carbone et
en premier lieu le marché dit réglementé
mise en place par le gouvernement du
Québec si le marché entre le Québec et
la Californie les gros pollueurs ont un
quota démission de gaz à effet de serre
annuel si les pollueurs dépassent leurs
émissions ils doivent acheter des droits
de polluées à un autre joueur du marché
ou encore dans les enchères du
gouvernement
il y a ensuite le marché volontaire
c'est le genre de crédit carbone que
vous pouvez acheter si vous voulez
compenser votre dernier voyage à Cuba
prenons l'exemple de la forêt Woodbury
qui fait partie du marché volontaire
avant l'achat par un partenaire de Fonds
d'action la forêt devait être récoltée
parce qu'elle est maintenant protégée
sont gestionnaires peut calculer combien
de carbone elle va séquestrer au lieu
qu'il soit relâché ce sont ces quantités
de carbone qui peuvent ensuite être
vendues sur le marché volontaire et
c'est comme ça que Fondaction monétise
la conservation pas en achetant la terre
mais en achetant le droit de revendre
des crédits carbone
vous êtes qui exactement
contre tout contre les gens qui polluent
la nature contre la justice sociale
faudrait changer certaines habitudes que
le profit ne soit pas toujours avant la
nature
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
présence du monde de la finance soulève
beaucoup d'espoir en voyant le secteur
privé protégé des tas mais pour
plusieurs il y a aussi le risque de voir
la nature simplement comme une source de
profit une commodité nature
un rôle à jouer que ce soit le milieu
économique les entreprises la finance le
social l'éducation on a tous un rôle à
jouer pour vaincre cette bataille là
mais c'est facile de tomber dans les
coupes blanches avec prudence
une critique qui revient souvent c'est
que les crédits carbone permet aux
pollueurs de se donner bonne conscience
parmi les sceptiques il y a Greenpeace
Canada
le potentiel de la finance sur les
enjeux de biodiversité ne se limitent
pas à la simple question de protection
du territoire les rapports
internationaux se multiplient pour
exiger que la finance dirige ses
capitaux vers des secteurs qui vont
restaurer la planète
les institutions
findrisme la conservation et
l'utilisation durable de la biodiversité
mais comment s'assurer que nous
investissements respectent nos objectifs
et qu'il ne tombe pas dans l'écho
blanche Chima est-ce qu'on peut faire
confiance au monde financier pour
renverser la vapeur pour changer les
choses on a besoin de ses capitaux là
donc il y a aucun état dans le monde qui
pesait je vais faire mon 30% et même
plus et restaurer avec son propre budget
d'une façon pragmatique c'est dommage à
dire mais la transition écologique qui
est nécessaire pour répondre aux
pressions des changements globaux crise
de biodiversité pollution systémique
changement climatique nos fenêtres
d'intervention sont très très courtes et
on a besoin des leviers de la finance
donc ça c'est c'est réel c'est vrai on a
besoin d'argent pour le faire mais la
dernière chose à faire c'est laisser le
marché pour le marché c'est à dire des
institutions financières économiques qui
vont déterminer quels sont les bons
cases les bonnes façons de faire pour
générer du rendement même si les valeurs
il est la volonté est louable au départ
il faut que ce soit balisé et c'est là
qu'il est un rôle à jouer qu'on soit au
niveau d'une municipalité d'une province
d'un pays de cadres internationaux on a
besoin de dire quels sont les
indicateurs donc quels sont les
paramètres selon lesquels je permet à
des gens d'investir dans la nature au
niveau des entreprises au même titre
qu'elle publie à chaque année leur
rapport annuel il va falloir aussi être
adéquatement outillés pour qu'on puisse
déclarer voici l'impact sur le climat et
voici l'impact sur la biodiversité si on
veut pouvoir corriger ce type d'approche
l'un des territoires qui perd le plus sa
biodiversité ces écosystèmes si le
périmètre urbain on connaît l'histoire
les villes se financent avec des taxes
municipales donc la valeur d'un
développement est plus attrayante que
celle d'un boisé depuis 20 ans l'indice
de verdure dans les villes canadiennes a
perdu en moyenne 8%. et quand la verdure
diminue les services écologiques
deviennent souvent moins efficaces
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que
souvent on va ignorer cette valeur de la
nature malheureusement on a tendance à
reconnaître une contribution naturelle
lorsque elle est perdue donne l'exemple
de la grille du frein donc que des films
de 10 à 20% des forêts urbaines dans le
sud du Québec 99% des freines sont
condamnés mais lorsqu'on voit devant
chez soi que trois grands arbres matures
disparaissent mais là on se rend compte
que c'était des îlots de fraîcheur que
c'était esthétique ça avait même une
valeur sur l'immeuble ou la maison qu'on
habite
on a acheté cette année pour 40 millions
de milieux naturels 500 hectares des
milieux naturels plus de 6.5 millions de
pieds carrés de milieu naturel qu'on a
protégé
à l'échelle du pays une centaine de
municipalités se sont regroupées pour
redonner de la valeur au milieu naturel
sur leur territoire
le réseau milite pour que la
contribution de la nature soit calculée
dans les bilans comptables des villes au
même titre que les infrastructures
municipales pour l'instant c'est une
minorité de municipalités qui font ces
calculs mais il serait pas étonnant de
voir cette façon de faire prendre de
l'ampleur
on rejoint Johanna et Kim une
scientifique et administratrice de ce
réseau municipal
on a souvent une idée que les solutions
c'est comme laine générique la
technologie mais en fait il y a plein de
solutions surtout pour les changements
climatiques qui utilisent les processus
naturels on parlerait de quoi pas comme
un exemple qu'on pourrait voir au Québec
on peut parler peut-être des millénaires
puis le Service de protection contre les
inondations quand il y a les inondations
les mieux humides et Vertigo alors il
peut protéger les villes qui sont plus
en aval ça donne quoi de mettre une
valeur économique sur des services
écologiques comme ça je pense que c'est
une question de transparence c'est une
telle valeur financière c'est pas
vraiment pris en compte on est décisions
économiques alors ça c'est une chose qui
c'est le gestion qui est importante les
villes ils ont une gestion des activités
partis il faut aussi une gestion des
actifs naturels qui les deux travaillent
ensemble pour les bénéfices des citoyens
il nous manque vraiment un cadre
institutionnel adéquat pour pouvoir se
dire quel est le bon élève et quel est
l'élève qui est un petit peu moins bon
disons celui qui est un petit peu à
progresser mais ça reste à l'échelle
municipale essentielle de faire ce bilan
naturel pour se dire voici comment ce
qu'on porte mon écosystème mon capital
naturel au même titre que je vous fais
un bilan de mon capital financier sinon
on est végan aveugle et c'est
catastrophique
[Musique]
finalement la nature a toujours eu une
valeur avant c'était le prix à la tonne
pour telle matière le prix au mètre
carré pour tel terrain
la crise climatique est celle de la
biodiversité nous force à revoir notre
rapport à l'environnement ce n'est plus
une question de voir ce que l'on peut
gagner financièrement mais plutôt de
comprendre ce que l'on va perdre
une idée
[Musique]
on a pris l'économie comme étant une
balise fondamentale pour déterminer
l'ensemble de nos actions mais on oublie
finalement la soutenabilité à long terme
de ces enjeux et c'est ce que le
changement climatique et la biodiversité
nous rappelle la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on est en 2022 et tenir ce discours a
l'air normal tout à fait acquis il y a
30 ou 40 ans c'était est-ce que vous
dites là au juste là